everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm today are going to be going
over game 10 from the 2013 World Chess
Championship between the current
champion anon and the highest red chess
player in the world Magnus Carlsen the
22 year old Norwegian superstar of chess
again if you haven't been keeping up
with the matches
we're in game 10 there's 12 games total
if that we need them up into this point
Magnus Carlsen has a three point lead so
anan has to win the next three games
just to go into quote-unquote chess
overtime where there'll be some
additional games played this is
definitely gonna be a tough feet forward
on all Magnus Carlsen has to do gets to
play white in game 10 and 12 if we need
them all he has to do is tie one of
these games and he is the new champion
so we're gonna go ahead and get into it
again this game White's gonna be played
by Magnus Carlsen anons gonna be playing
the black pieces
Magnus starts out with Pawnee 4 and we
see the very sharp defense from anon
knowing that he has to play for a win
cannot draw in this particular position
decides to go for the very sharp
Sicilian defense which plays extremely
well for black can really get into some
complicated variations if White's not
careful so after Knight to f3 pawn d6 we
now have the Moscow variation definitely
something we don't see too often but it
is a very sharp way to play in this
Sicilian defense if we kind of look at
it what's black looking to do well he
wants to go ahead and castle on the King
side have this pin go away and then he
can really activate this Knight it is
sometimes a little bit difficult if
white decides not to exchange here on d7
to get this light squared bishop
involved into the game so there's
something to think about later on though
you could see a push forward of pawn to
a6 and then pawn to b5 after that to
kind of give some breathing room if
black really wanted to get his light
squared bishop involved into the game
Magnus Carlsen decides to continue to
push forward again pretty common for
white against these Sicilian defense
takes with his Queen here on d4 and
after the pond pushing forward to a six
magnets just decides to just go ahead
and take here on D seven again he could
have come back here and then back here
on B three and then try to control this
long diagonal but decided just to go
ahead and exchange off very similar to
what we saw a game before knowing that
he had a two-game lead going into game
nine was always looking to make things
less complicated to get a lot of the
more powerful pieces off the board kind
of get to an end game where he's more
comfortable and try to avoid anything
too crazy in this particular match so we
see here a pawn c4 pretty interesting
again Magnus Carlsen had a lot of
variations he could go from here Bishop
to e3 is pretty common
you could castle on the kingside right
away even pawn pushing forward to e5
does have an option instead decides to
go ahead and push forward with pawn to
c4 this is the semi open file that black
could kind of control he could bring his
rook over here to see a try to put a lot
of pressure on that but this really
allows him to be a lot more aggressive
than passive which is kind of
interesting knowing that all he has to
do is play for a draw Magnus Carlsen
still being pretty aggressive in this
opening so now we see Knight to f5 again
getting ready to get the rest of his
pieces develops we can castle on the
Kings side get some safety now we see
the bishop come out again the dark
square bishop for white a lot of times
is a hazard doesn't do too much so just
has to go ahead and bring it out go
ahead and pin down this knight here we
see the pawn to e6 kind of given some
breathing room so the bishop can come in
here to e7 very logical move and now
nice to see three in both sides doing
exactly what we expect them to do get
all their pieces developed as we go in
towards the middle game and now we see
Bishop d7 Castle and then we're gonna go
ahead and first see the bishop come here
to c6 again could have seen the
immediate just castle on the King side
but recognizes that he wants to have
some sort of counter attack in the
center of the board and this someone
does that so he has you know the bishop
here on c6 he has the night here on f6
both attacking this pawn on e4 so trying
to get some counter attack in the center
of the board we now see the Queen just
come back here to d3
again you really just don't want it to
be too much in the center of the board
because it doesn't really have a super
strong attack you don't want your
opponent kind of just forcing your moves
from the Queen so just bringing back to
d3 it's still active still protecting
this pawn here on e4 but doesn't want to
have too much in this here on the board
now as he castle on the Kings side which
again we could have seen beforehand and
then the Knights gonna come here at the
d4 if we kind of look at from from both
sides what does white really want to do
while white has really dominating the
center of the board if we kind of look
at you know his Knights he's controlling
all the critical squares that he needs
to he has some nice little outpost he
can get to this dark square Bishop isn't
doing too much so you may want to
exchange this at some point but he does
have his rooks connected this is very
good he controls this semi-open file on
the D file so this is gonna be very good
but he wants to just maintain pressure
especially on these light squares
because he does have both of his pawns
here on c4 and E 4 so this is kind of
what he's looking for
if we look from black an on really wants
to get out of his cramped position so he
has developed most of his pieces does
need to get his queen of all them to the
game but he's very very crimped he
doesn't have really any way to counter
play right now more than likely he's
gonna try to break through in the center
of the board he doesn't really have a
lot of pawn structure to do anything on
the Queen side so his best bet is to
dominate the center of the board get out
of his cramped position and then try to
find some sort of imbalance in Magnus
Carlsen display hopefully magnus carlsen
blunders and black can go ahead and get
a win from this game so the Knights
gonna come to d4 more central square for
this Knights and then we see the rook
swing over to c8 again the semi-open
file works always do well on open files
or semi open file so getting this rook
over here is definitely good once this
bishop moves it's gonna just really
reign havoc on this long file right here
then pawn to b3 again just strengthening
the pawn structure for white it's gonna
be very difficult for black to again
push on this Queen side so something's
got to give now the Queen's going to
come to c7
it's a more active square for this Queen
it does connect the rooks back here so
black has now completed his development
in the game and that's just gonna take
here on c6 doesn't want this light
square Bishop just dominating this here
on the board again this knight here
wasn't doing too much this knight on c3
is controlling the critical squares that
white really wants to so this just kind
of takes one of the attackers the bishop
here on c6 from those critical squares
that White's trying to hold down then
the stern of the board so after he takes
this rifts gonna swing over here to c1
trying to semi defend the semi open file
that the rook here on c8 is attacking
and then pawn here to h6 kicking it back
so the bishop is just going to come back
here to e3 he's still active square for
this bishop you don't want to bring it
back too far it's not going to be
involved into the game but you also
don't want to get in a point where it's
not protected it can't really do
anything in the fight so III definitely
active square where it's still
controlling some of these squares in the
center which both sides are really
fighting for right now the Knights gonna
come back here to d7 try to get more
placement again before it was being
pinned down now that it's not it can
kind of move around the board and get
into a better position the bishop is
gonna come here to d4 probably the best
square where magnus carlsen really wants
this it can start to attack you know
some of these squares over here the g7
could be an issue if the Queen comes
over here to g3 start to have an attack
we could even bring some of the rooks
over here start to launch an attack this
is definitely gonna be very dangerous
for black if he's not ready for it anong
continued with rook over to d8
controlling the center of the board with
his rooks from the distance and then
pawn to h3 kind of a just waiting move
right here does allow him to have some
breathing room with his King if he ever
needs to doesn't have to worry about any
back rank make or anything that could
potentially come up
Magnus cross him playing it very safe
making sure that he doesn't make any big
errors that could potentially giving out
a win
give him some momentum going into games
11 and 12 the Queen comes back here to
c7 no rule great scare squares for the
Queen to come to and so it's just kind
of a waiting game of who's gonna strike
first and who's
gonna try to make something happen in
the center of the board the works gonna
swing over again controlling the semi
open files always important Queens gonna
come over to a5 not really attacking too
much but it does allow it to kind of
control this fifth rank right here I can
kind of move back and forth the Queen's
gonna come back here to d2
it is attacking this pawn over here on
h6 also still attacking and defending
this square here on c3 very important
he's gonna come to f8 doesn't want to
get into any problems of all these
diagonals right here again we already
talked about what would happen if we had
a queen over here on the G rank this is
definitely gonna be very tough to deal
with
so we have the Queen come over here
after this Knight moves you know could
come to e 2 or something we do have this
double barrel here where the bishop and
Queen are both attacking the pawn here
on g7 so very important to protect that
the King's just gonna come back here
wasn't doing too much so why is now
gonna push forward on the Queen side
it's gonna be very difficult to really
find any openings on the Queen side but
Magnus Carlsen decides to push forward
this does however leave a small weakness
here on b3 when your opponent moves you
always look at what was left behind this
pawn on a 2 was defending this pawn so
if black can start to find a way to take
some pieces off the board and then
attack this pawn on b3 this definitely
isn't imbalanced that Magnus Carlsen has
on the board right now but it is very
difficult to actually find a way to
attack this the Queen's are going to
come over to h5 just kind of going back
and forth it's not really able to do too
much right now but it does kind of
defend these squares that we talked
about so Knight to e2 kind of opening up
the door and then the bishops gonna come
to f6 again had to kind of block this
off but that's completely fine the
Brooks is going to swing up here is we
talked about getting ready to come over
to here to g3 starting to launch an
attack on the G file and so there's an
exchange this is great for Magnus
Carlsen he wants to get pieces off the
board that's his main goal right now so
anytime your opponent wants to give up
his last bishop that's gonna be
applauded by Magnus Carlsen the Queen's
going to come here to e5 and then we
have the Queen centralized
here to d2 controlling the semi open
file then that's gonna come to f6 trying
to control the center of the board a
little bit more of these light squares
that we talked about it wasn't doing too
much back here on d7 and then this rook
swings over here to e3 putting some more
support on this pawn on e4 that this
Knight is now attacking now that works
gonna swing here to d7 so that it can
have double protection if the rook wants
to swing over here to the 8th does allow
him you know also to protect this 7th
rink as well the pawns gonna push
forward to a5 again it's not doing too
much this is still protected by this
Queen on d2 so just making sure that the
nan can't push forward any more on the
Queen side the next move from the NAM
was definitely pretty interesting one of
the many blunders that he's had in this
tournament and they played Queen here to
g5 now as Queen here on e5 was very
central great square for the Queen
wasn't going to be doing too much but it
really prevented white from dominating
the center of the board again if we look
at this there's one thing that both
sides are trying to do and that's when
the center of the board if you can win
the center of the board you can actually
go on to win this particular game where
I talked about is very tough on the
Queen side both King sides are very very
secure to the Queen and the center here
on e5 was gonna be completely okay when
you bring the Queen over here to g5 that
allows Magnus Carlsen to play the move
e5 and if you've seen any of my other
videos you know that it's not always
about the pieces you have on the board
it's about the pieces you have that are
involved in the fight in this particular
case this completely takes out the Queen
in the fight the center of the board is
now blocked off because of this pawn on
e5 and white now has the advantage this
pawns attacking the knight so the
Knights gonna have to move the pawn
can't take back here because the rooks
just gonna fall the knight takes and
then the Queen takes again this is gonna
be very very good for white it's
obviously got enough material so instead
the Knights gonna have to move moves
back to e8 this is good squared because
it does defend this pawn here on d6
which White's kind of putting all his
pressure on but after Knight to c3 again
this just adds more and more pressure on
black and black just gonna have to
really defend here and this
the move that magnus carlsen probably
should have made it's the move that he
didn't make in the particular game after
the news conference he said he just
overlooked it this was definitely a much
better move but in the particular game
he chose a different Avenue from here
again if we look at it the knight can
come to a four it can then come to b6
nice little outpost for this night here
on b6 adding a lot of pressure how does
black really defend again we're really
trying to attack the score on d6 you can
see this rook swing down here to c6
trying to add another defender here
again the Knights gonna come to a force
we talked about getting ready to come up
over here to b6 we could have the Queen
come up here to see seven try to add
another defender after the knight comes
to b6 the rook may swing back here to d8
again all of these squares all of these
rooks the knight the queen
none of them are doing anything except
trying to defend the square here on d6
white can go ahead and he can start to
be a little bit more aggressive he can
play the rook over here to d3 getting
ready to bring his queen to h6 take a
free pawn there if he wants to this is
all gonna be very good and black really
can't do much in the particular game
even if black doesn't try to hold on to
this if we look at this Knight right
here this knight can always come over
here to e4 forking the Queen and
potentially another move gonna be very
difficult now in the particular game
Magnus Carlsen actually decided to go
ahead and take with his pawn here on d6
because he does have two attackers right
here and there's only two defenders but
anon just simply played the rook here to
c6 getting back that material right away
so bang this cross and he even admitted
he said hey I jumped and thought I saw
an opportunity to go ahead and win
material when sometimes if your opponent
makes a mistake getting material is not
what you want to do adding pressure and
tension to the board and cramping your
opponent's tile so all of their pieces
are forced to control and defend one
pawn and the center of the board
sometimes is much more powerful but
again Magnus Carlsen still has a lead in
the game and is still trying to control
the center of the board
now this pawn is going to push forward
you F for knowing that there's already
tension in the sin of the board so
forcing this black queen to move the
Queen's gonna come back and then the
rooks can swing over here to d3 lining
up the center of the board right here
and then we just start to see an
exchange Adnan decides to go ahead and
take with his rook here on these six and
then we just see pieces just flying off
the board right here and then we get
into a knight in game now there's a few
things that nan has going for him the
first thing is he's down three games the
next one is the night in game especially
with a bunch of pawns it's very
difficult to win if you're playing
someone good
his third problem is his opponent is 22
years old and he has tons of energy and
he loves the endgame particularly a
knight in game it's virtually impossible
for him to get anything out of this
especially with Magnus Carlsen sitting
across the board most people actually
thought that but this particular case
just players would just shake their
hands and just call it a draw and Magnus
Carlsen will be champion they decided
for the fans to go ahead and play this
out and so we see the night in game both
sides centralizing their King King
obviously in the end game is a very
important piece to go ahead and get
involved and so we see a lot of
maneuvering around the board both sides
trying to figure out what they want to
do Magnus Carlsen did have the option
after f6 here to play a pretty
interesting move he could have played
Knight here to h5 this would have kind
of opened the door the King could have
now come to d7 and then we could have
pushed forward on b4 this would have
been pretty interesting even could have
given up his night here on h5 to go
ahead and push on the Queen side here
getting the Queen racing his opponent
for a queen over here Magnus Carlsen
however saying that with the time he
didn't want to get into any complicated
lines which h5 is complicated even
though it actually gives Magnus Carlsen
an advantage in the game he probably
could have gone on to win I think if he
wanted to but he said hey it was just
too crazy he was looking all the
variations he just didn't want to be
thinking anymore it was much easier for
him to just go ahead and play Knight
here to G
because it was almost a force to draw
from here so the night's gonna take and
then both sides to start to exchange
pieces off the board he immediately just
gives up his night knowing that he can
just come over here and immediately
start to take these pawns right here and
so from here we have four pawns to a
night in a pond and then it's just kind
of a race and again this goes down
fifteen moves from where they were but
these are the type of in games that
Magnus Carlsen can easily calculate in
his head and he knew that giving up at
night he was gonna be able to race here
and get his Queen first and then he
could kind of dictate from here so the
Queen's gonna come we're gonna have a
few moves and he's actually gonna force
his opponent to trade off Queens with
the Queen coming here to b6 the queen is
forced to take here on b6 or it would be
lost and so after it takes black no
longer has sufficient material to
checkmate you can't just checkmate with
it with your knight and so Magnus
Carlsen doesn't even really care it
doesn't even try to do too much and then
after this point it is a draw Magnus
Carlsen is the new world champion 22
years of age about to turn 23 I think
it's going to be huge for chest just a
dominating performance from him didn't
drop one game to the reigning champion
so after ten games unfortunately for the
viewers there are no 11 and 12 games
because we do have a champion those
games would be meaningless but Magnus
Carlsen has now won he is the champion
hopefully you guys have enjoyed this
series I'm definitely going to be doing
a lot more commentary on some of the
major tournaments so hopefully you enjoy
this learn from it and I'll see you all
in the next major tournament Congrats
Magnus Carlsen
see you guys